okay oh god I drank the booze okay well
I guess I'm not making molotov that I do
that to extra but you have an excuse cuz
you're Irish
yeah at what point does that become
offensive to say that Irish people drink
or is that never offensive yes you can't
really offend Irish people some people
will say you can but really know
everybody my name is Margo lion welcome
back to the forest with jacksepticeye
say hi chick
hi guys jacksepticeye here go space
Broncos okay I like how you took on your
Australian accent good a voice I
potentially have I could do some
impressions wouldn't you oh no I can't
no you could you can do some of them I
can do which ones can I do let's have an
abortion
you didn't Mortimer pretty good guy with
a deep voice can yes you can do well
it's a girl
oh god that's just offensive I feel so
bad because you know I don't mean to
offend but some people take it wrong way
and they're like yeah you hate such and
such and like some people did not take
that video well like what their friends
know I hang out with these people on on
a regular basis but no no I'm instantly
okay yeah I'm gonna go down there if I
fall will this kill me because they
remember fall yeah climb-climb-climb
that's so stupid though also these guys
are really freaking out
okay I'm gonna climb down we need to eat
lima now fire on the beach I made a fire
on the beach oh god we're climbing down
together you're just like hey I'm gonna
start the fire and we're gonna cook
rabbits or something wait well I have no
sprint so I'm I have no energy this is a
good search this episode
hey well there's a first time for you to
die I already died twice as bad as
everyone says
people say dying is bad that's okay yeah
it's like amazingly you like you came
back quick yeah two three four five six
seven eight ten natives oh I got we
walked into the fire Brazil on fire why
not I know that used to be my strategy
to kill ya put the fire up here we go I
got my big lighter
absolutely not yeah get away from here
but those are bad bears right they all
ran all we dove astray because I'm the
leader and I'm the survivalist of this
group okay I see berries berries blue
good for you yes I thought it was
berries too bad for you berries group
good for clues for poop that's what it
means
No if the berries are white they're all
right my coat doesn't work though I just
made it up no the berries why
we're not all right yeah okay we'll
change it then if the prairies are Weiss
they're full of shite okay there but
that's a bit that's a better one okay so
white and black berries are bad but
blueberries are good yeah
blueberries you're good muffins why
muffins good Boober same kind of my head
news so cases we can get chocolate where
where are you I have an army behind me
oh there you are
I'm right in front of you oh I said
there you are why don't you listen to me
because 5000 mile different show you
know what just it's too much okay if
this sort of work communication we put
that we were married
okay now we're married also if you guys
see me look in different areas at
cameras it's cuz I have two cameras two
cameras cuz I have two camcorder and
then if the webcam for you what way
twice I'm a queen webcam dissent to use
you could put it in your video and
that's my camcorder for me so important
I can't acquire that's right
yes I ran with Baba he sent me like 10
gigs of his webcam for don't starve and
it was just a nightmare getting that is
so bad and I have like 60 60 FPS webcam
so yeah wait what webcam yes well
camcorder could you run that by me
what's it for our honeymoon which I'm
guessing that this is our honeymoon
which is a this is the worst honeymoon
we didn't get any nookie yet you've died
twice you think doesn't kill the romance
are you just post replied shares what
I'm a wizard
okay wait
do you see shirt still don't see sharks
oh I see dead sharks yeah if you see a
shark crouch and go no don't touch it
don't touch it you touched it well was I
not supposed to there are masculine
clothes see what do you do crouched to
go to its nose and it multiplies
these [ __ ] are following us wait see
but you do it again wait hi didn't work
what am i doing yeah it doesn't work
that way broke a bunch of ball let's get
away from the marching army moon like
Mac EMU and Jackie Rooney so we'll see
take ourselves so seriously in this
profession oh my god yes did I mention
how professional my recording setup was
yeah are you said that recording on a
shoe shoe I forgot my bean bag I don't
feel the same without it you know I
don't feel like a Mamet up my bean bag
wait why are we marching towards one of
their villages oh we I'm following you
you just ran away go on the leader now
you agree I just ate some marigold why
did you eat marigolds there there helps
apparently does that happen in real life
no don't be Webster eating random plants
don't do that
you don't even do any money perhaps like
aloe vera it's good for you they're good
for your skin not for inside of you well
have you eaten it to commit to this as
long as it take and then I died that's
how bad it was good okay anyway so what
is our next goal now that we've kind of
escaped me maybe find a cave I bet in a
cave it's filled with nightmares yeah
that's good it was two of us now we can
survive with axes let me ask you a
question
oh there's a dead guy here yeah hey
buddy some kind of effigy here yeah wait
let me clear these plants so I can see
you better
those are some nice tighty whiteys you
have I took his shirt
so those blade they shoved his phone
going down his throat yeah can you
settle it down his neck can you see this
guy he has like he is an impressive
package oh he's got a night let me just
go ahead let me clear this that you
didn't clear out of the way sorry sorry
sorry sorry
totally meant to do that he's a nice
bulge going on ooh yeah that's why they
kills you they were just jealous yeah I
know let me just get a nice zoom on that
oh I went through him thank God through
him thank God they did not commit to
these character models right way through
it's weird cuz they did the boob physics
why not carry through on the day the
male models of the cannibals don't even
have junk like it's no okay I'm not
gonna like start that that's a whole
tumblr war that I am NOT starting wait
what are you
I don't want to know what you're
starting but I'm kind of curious as to
what you thought you were sturdy ISM
fascism Oh
fascism how dare you talk about fascists
fascists have rights too
oh god that's what I don't even know
what fascism or communism comunism I
think that actually is the same thing
yeah just wait I will say I am NOT a
dirty Irish communist like Jack over
there I'm an American
are you a liberal I'm not gonna say I
have no idea the difference oh yeah
that's right because in Britain like
liberal and liberal and conservative are
flipped in the UK even here like even
England oh here's mushrooms you can try
them if you wear mushrooms here are my
feet if you build enough effigies do you
eventually turn into a cannibal I hope
so
I never heard that I tried building a
lot of effigies and it didn't work but
okay is there anything good in this
place
oh god I can't see
Oh game crashed is that a thing that's
the thing for a while but yeah okay so
we got nothing else to fill for this
episode I guess blame Jack the King
later this game my games working his
crashed I'm back in the game but it
restarted me Oh No well you can just
grab your stuff with the plane nothing
much has changed why don't we just build
a thing at the plane don't talk on the
walkie-talkies fine okay so anyway I
guess that's it for this episode we will
in between will build a camp so that we
don't lose progress until the next yes
and waste all your time
thanks again Jack for being here thank
you again everybody there for watching
and as always we will see you